he's got the optimal position in fact
yes and now fa will have to made that
move with one second did he make it with
1 second oh my
goodness oh my goodness and now the
white king wants oh look at that
hesitation I know and Bishop will come
to D5 setting up a discover check that
Fabby says you can
have
okay King
defended Fabby wants to get out of the
last rank that is the ideal position for
for Ray Robson to try to Checkmate the
king and makes defense that much more
trickier King C3 no he didn't play King
C3 don't like that decision but I would
I would think that Fabby has studded
this end game of course a million times
but especially around the world
championship match of 2018 you just
revised this anyway oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh Fabby
flagged oh my
word half a point lead half a point lead
with one round to spare